hey everybody welcome to the box this is
a little one off planet coaster project
that I decided to work on just because I
had the idea and I just couldn't help
but turn it into something real to be
honest though I've had this idea for a
really long time for a few years now
even and to be completely honest it's
not even my idea
in 2008 a YouTube user by the name of
moon Kim for the win uploaded a
rollercoaster tycoon 3 coaster called
the box and this turned out to be one of
the most popular rollercoaster tycoon 3
videos ever and because it was such an
easy to do formats because really all he
did was create a simple rollercoaster
layout and then build a check a sort of
checkered pattern building around it to
make it feel like a box so because of
this very simple strategy to making this
video it's one that God repeated many
many times over by different people and
at this point I think there are over 50
the box videos on YouTube and that is
really just the standard the box series
made by different people there are all
kinds of variations on this as well with
all kinds of different color schemes
there's also a video called up is down
by Luke Lord which I believe is probably
inspired by the books because it's
pretty much just a the box coaster with
a different building around it but the
same format exists for all of these
videos it is always a coaster inside a
sort of chessboard style building where
you basically kind of lose your
orientation sometimes regarding what is
up and what is down and somebody has
made a box coaster in planet coaster as
well but personally I've always wanted
to try and take this idea and take it to
the next level in a sense that I wanted
to try it in a way that would be
realistically plausible a lot of the box
coasters are huge completely unrealistic
and would never be built in real life
and most definitely don't tend to have
layouts that would
work in real life featuring all kinds of
inversions and things like that are
completely impossible so I would love to
try and see if it's possible to make a
quote-unquote realistic the box coaster
that at least you know could be feasibly
built and survivable if you ride it and
in addition to that I've always had some
lighting issues with the box coasters
because usually the lighting was kind of
unrealistic so for this one I'm going to
try to make it dark and actually light
it up with lights as well and finally
just as a way to add some flare to the
whole disorienting experience of it I
decided to make it a mouse on a spinning
coaster specifically the one that can go
upside down which the game technically
doesn't have also what am I saying Mario
Sona it's a Mac spinning coaster but
yeah it's something that works it's
based on I guess time traveler in real
life although there are now going to be
more of these inverting spinning
coasters popping up in different
countries as well I believe pop salons
Belgium is going to get one as well
either way they're a hot new thing on
the block and they're probably one of
the coolest most disorienting coasters
out there so to me it felt like the
perfect opportunity to make a the book
style coaster that is truly disorienting
and hopefully to some extent realistic
as well so as you can see I've worked
out the basic layout for the coaster
honestly I didn't put too much time into
actually making it smooth because it's
it would take a lot of time with not
that much return-on-investment I figured
especially given the fact that it's a
spinning coaster I don't think that
little pumps in the layout will be that
noticeable but the layout itself is also
just quite simple it mostly features a
lot of dive loops and over-banked turns
because these are the elements that well
for one they fit very well into this
super limited amount of space that I
have inside this box but also I think
they're really disorienting elements
they're elements where you can just
constantly Bank in different directions
and make it very confusing whether
you're upside down or not just make it
confusing in general whether you're
going
through a half loop or just going
through a curve on one of the sides of
this box it's just I feel like these
elements flow really well into each
other when it comes to trying to make a
disorienting coaster where you can't
tell what's up and down but at the same
time not a coaster where the g-forces
are gonna be ridiculous
so at any time especially during the
inversions you will have positive forces
on this coaster there is no air time on
it of course there's some hang time but
you never get unrealistic moments where
you're hanging by your lap bar on a
curve that is banked the other way
around or anything like that's based on
g-forces this coaster should be pretty
writable and not subject the people - to
crazy forces so really my only concern
at this point is that if you were to
write this in real life you might be
able to tell from the g-forces whether
you're up or down but I also have to say
that at the end of the day positive
g-forces are positive g-forces so I
don't think that given this sort of
environment your body would be very good
at telling whether you're going through
positive g-forces in a turn or whether
you're going through positive g-force in
a loop but that's hard to tell because
this kind of coaster doesn't really
exist in real life
now one of the other tricks that I try
to use to feasibly make this coaster
feel much more confusing is I tried to
connect supports to the closest wall to
whichever track piece I was supporting
so down on the ground here you can see
that the supports are just simply
vertical as they would normally be but
then on the sides when the track comes
close to one of the walls of the box I
decided to add supports that are
horizontal so it kind of feels like
those walls could be you know the ground
as well and then when it comes to the
track pieces that are on the ceiling
those are attached also to the ceiling
it also kind of helps to not make this
entire box a giant mess of supports
because with this layout it would
definitely turn into that if I were to
connect everything to the ground now I'm
not entirely sure you know on an
engineering level how feasible this is
but in my mind
and you just have supports that are
suspended from the ceiling on top and
then the supports on the side even
though they connect to the walls in a
strange way I did add you know diagonal
lateral supports to it as well so from
my knowledge I think this thing should
be able to hold its weight obviously I'm
not an engineer who like calculates
exactly what the forces on the track are
going to be and whether it would work
out well but I think it's plausible
enough that a co so we could be built
this way so if you look for instance at
the support that I just built it's one
support that's on the side of the walls
but you can see that there's a
horizontal beam and then there is a
diagonal beam underneath that supporting
net
so that's realistic enough but at the
same time it looks like a support that
could also be attached to the ground you
never know
now that is everything I did for the
main chaotic piece of this layouts but
there is a mid-course break run where
you're sort of disorienting illusion
gets broken for a second just because
for well I guess realism reasons I also
wanted to give this write a decent
throughput and these trains aren't too
large so I feel like the capacity of
this ride would be way too limited if it
didn't have a mid-course brake run so
after all of the madness inside that box
we go into a mid-course brake run where
for a second I think you get a decent
idea of what is up and down and also
after that I didn't have too much height
to play with anymore so I couldn't do
any really crazy elements anymore but
there was one thing that I've always
wanted to try and that is build a
corkscrew with a spinning coaster inside
a room where you also can tell what is
up or down so that is really the the
focus of this set at the second section
of the ride right here other than that I
have to say that I'm just going to theme
everything in a super basic way there
are just going to be concrete walls all
around this thing because it's not
really supposed to have a theme aside
from being the box
I guess it's definitely not here to be a
beautiful ride really my only goal is to
disorient people with layouts
would honestly just be feasible and
understandable outside of the context of
this disorienting box so for this
corkscrew I'm just building a small mini
box with the same checkerboard pattern
and I'm not sure you know if it looks
very disorienting right now but honestly
when I tried testing this thing even
knowing what this row is like it's
really hard to tell what's up and down
as you're on the right because with a
spinning coaster you start losing points
of reference and I think this is a
crucial difference with a regular
coaster I think you can always find
these little points of reference where
you can tell whether you're upside down
or not depending on you know in real
life how you feel but even in the game
you can see it you can see sometimes
where the ground is or you can have a
feeling for what elements are shaped
like and you can recognize which part of
an element would be you know upside down
and which wouldn't so for a loop for
instance you can always see that the the
tightest part of the inversion is always
the top and it's always this at the
section where upside down because that's
where you have the slowest speeds but
you still maintain some of the same
g-force
so of course loops are always teardrop
shaped so just based on that track
shaping you can usually tell whether
you're upside down or not but with the
spinning coaster I think it's different
because you just start spinning in all
these crazy directions especially if the
spin is completely unlocked so there's
not a lot to hold on to you just
constantly see different things and even
inside this roll which is really just
one simple corkscrew and really
shouldn't be all that disorienting
anyway as soon as you start spinning
into that thing and you're spinning
because well the track is literally
rotating but at the same time the car is
also spinning on its own axis it just
gets too confusing to keep track of
where you're going I feel like you could
compare this maybe two okay so for my
experience perhaps the vertigo flat ride
in Tivoli Gardens in Copenhagen which
honestly is my favorite flat ride in the
world but it has two major sections a
has one part of the right where it spins
just really quickly it's just a plane on
a stick that is literally just what the
whole flat right is it's a plane on a
giant stick like a one plane Ferris
wheel that just spins really fast it
sounds boring but it's so intense that
it's honestly a really cool flat ride
but it also has a section of the ride
where it's not just the the large metal
arm that the plane is attached to that
spins but also the plane starts spinning
on its own axis and I think it creates a
similar effect to what you get with an
inverting spinning coaster I feel like
your body can maintain a decent idea of
what direction you're going if you're
spinning in one direction but as soon as
two different directions of spinning in
a 3d space are involved it just becomes
way too confusing so I'm kind of relying
also on that in this whole build now I
have to say at this point the coaster
itself is pretty much finished I just
wanted to finish off this whole thing by
adding a sort of exterior area around it
but it's just kind of I don't know how I
should put it it's just kind of for my
own sense of suspense of disbelief then
it could be a real coaster because at
the end of the day I'm not actually
gonna theme the outside of this or
anything it's just there to make it
believable that it could be a real-life
coaster inside a real knife dark ride
box which to be fair I think the
building could also reasonably fit into
because it's not that large of a
building and as you might have noticed I
did sink the layout into the ground so
that in the building wouldn't stick out
above the landscape that much so yeah
all things considered it's not you know
bigger than comparable indoor coasters
like rock on roller coaster for instance
so all things considered I I would
consider this as sort of concepts of
what the theme parks could do I don't
think anything Park is ever going to
build an indoor coaster like this but if
anybody ever comes up with the idea and
has the money for it then here's the
concept I think it's something cool and
something feasible honestly
that would be really cool to see in real
life we know we have the technology for
inverting spinning coasters now let's
make one indoors and make it so that you
can never tell which way you're going
that would be super awesome anyway
that's it for the time-lapse I'm gonna
leave you guys with some cinematic
footage and a POV of course and I hope
you enjoyed this little experiment bye
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]